When you were in Thailand, did you see any lady boys? I did not know.
That was kind of.
Yeah. Push it to the limit. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Brody Stevens,
a great light Brody Stevens, funniest, Instagram clip.
You said he pushed it to the limit in times.
Like I push it to the limit and that culture and I pushed it to the limb. Mr.
Little Aster was like, what do you mean? He's like, I push it to the limit.
It's like, well,
I should say I pushed and pushed to the limit in Thailand with the lady.
I mean, by the way, Thailand fascinating, you know,
you go to China and there's the three T's. You can't bring up what? Right.
Taiwan, Tibet, and Tiana, Tiananmen square. And then you think like,
as Americans, you think, Oh wow, there's this restriction.
There's this government influence. And by the way,
they have a rating scale of behavior for individuals.
There's facial recognition. It's like, it's stuff that freaks you out.
And then we went to Thailand and Thailand. There's a,
it's a royalty, right? It's a,
it's a funeral system and there's billboards up of the King around.
And you're like, what is that guy in the movie? And they're like, no,
that's the King. And they're like, can't talk about the King. And you're like,
we can't talk about the King. They're like, you can't talk about that.
Can't bring up King. And I you're like, well, that seems silly. Yeah.
And then you go to Singapore and you go, and they're like, you can't chew gum.
You know? Like it makes communist trying to appear like
rational adults. Yeah.
You know what I mean? It's like, you can't catch.
Singapore. You can't chew gum. What's the reason, uh,
I think it's filth. It's a clean city, right? It's a point city,
but you know, I mean, so was soul. So is, uh, Tokyo.
But, uh, and again, I was in Singapore two days. What do I know about Singapore?
Nothing. Yeah. But it's like, that's pretty weird. Yeah. I mean,
that's pretty strange. You can, you know, you can't treat gum prostitution.
There's some prostitutes bouncing around, you know, like with my kids, I'm like,
don't talk to that lady. You know what I mean? It's not like it's rampant,
but it's like Singapore. It's like Vegas where they're like, you know what?
Let's get rid of gum. Yeah.
In Japan. Aren't you not allowed to talk on the train?
I dunno. It wasn't on the tray. I wasn't on the tray, Japanese, uh,
culture. Very interesting. Like, um, you know, the,
the cabs they opened the door for you, you don't open the door.
They get right out and open. But no, no.
There's a lever on the inside where the door opens.
And then there's a lot of culture of like put the card down there.
Like essentially I don't want to touch you white beast kind of stuff.
Interesting. But it's fascinating. You know, Korea,
Japan, everyone's very dolled up, like dressed up.
Like you're like the bouncer and he looks great and it's
not like he's had a nightclub. You know what I mean? It's bouncers
fascinating because you've been everywhere. You've, you've kind of,
you think you've been like all over the, almost every place. And I mean,
I wish I wish I was in South America. I want to go to, I want to go to India.
I want to go to South America. You think of fans there? I don't probably not.
But, uh, fans and Taiwan, India,
the unifying language is English. But I think what I had heard is that,
you know, there's good comedians that are Indians,
so they don't need know name one, but I don't know.
No, but my
son Manasseh, no.
So there's, they don't. And,
and some of it is the economy of these places, supposedly. And, uh,
like I wanted to go to the Philippines and, uh, um, it didn't work out,
but like supposedly the Philippines, like people can't like,
whereas in Singapore, I think the ticket was a hundred us dollars.
Whereas in like the Philippines, it's like 10.
And if you're trying to pay for a flight there, you know, that's a lot of money.
Holy. A hundred. So it's like, but it's, it's, you know,
international shows I performed in Athens. I said, hi to all your family.
And uh, but tonight email you tell me about it. Yeah. It was amazing.
And because most of the audience you go to,
you do these international shows and some of the audience is,
uh ex-pat. And some of it is say, uh, people that, you know,
studied in America or studied in Canada or something like that.
But in an Athens, it was a lot of,
it was a lot of, uh,
Greeks that spoke English as a second language didn't necessarily,
uh, study in the U S I mean,
obviously the Greek and American community is very close. You know,
everyone has a relative there or here, or you're a Maine,
but it was pretty interesting. Like, it's like, that's definitely a place,
you know, for, you know, uh, Yonis and you know,
like you've have that character.
But I think you said like that character might not work in Greece,
Turkey. He can't even go over there.
So there's Turkish people that send him death threats. Well, no,
actually Greeks I've gotten Greek death threats from that character. Yeah. Yeah.
Cause they just, Greeks Greeks are very prideful. Yeah. He probably got that.
Yeah. And they just feel like the character makes Greeks look bad.
Cause I kinda, you know, th th th the characters,
all the foibles of Greek culture, right.
Wrapped up in one such like an international comedian,
like you've got fans all over the world,
who've ever shown up to a country or a city where like,
just majority of the audience didn't speak English.
And you just had a really tough time. Well, I mean, it's,
I think there's different, uh, different.
And I appreciate you saying that, but like,
I'm just doing it cause I like to travel, but like, it depends on the situation.
Selling tickets. I mean, you were playing kick moves. Tickets, Jimmy, Jimmy,
Gavin Jimmy G the kid does not have a day job. You dumb British man
sells tickets. It, I think.
I think performing in the UK is weirder than performing in Copenhagen.
Wow.
Because I think that in Copenhagen or, uh,
Athens,
people that are going to learn English have consumed American entertainment.
Whereas the UK, they have their own culture. Like I think like what works,
uh, you know, uh, you know, I mean, not to get too nerdy, but like,
I think the British love,
they love super intellectual and they love,
uh, American anger. Right? So they love bill burrow. They loved bill Hicks.
You know, they love Louis Black,
but like an observational guy like me, uh,
it's not as, uh, like they've got their own version of it. You know what I mean?
So I think, um, but other countries where they don't, yeah,
they don't, uh, do subtitles. So like Scandinavia, they don't,
they just put the American shows on, they don't do subtitles.
Whereas in France and Germany, they would dub them. There's 60 million people.
Why not? It.
Might as well. Well, yeah, cause to, I mean, you know me,
I've told you honestly, and anytime anybody asks, like, who's your career?
Who do you want your career to get to? And it's always you,
because I see like how you take your family everywhere.
And like that experience. I, you know, cause I got a three-year-old daughter.
I'm always thinking about like that experience for your kids must be like nuts.
It's beautiful. It's like, I will, I would argue, like,
I know you said it was spring break,
but like taking your kids to those countries, even taking them out of school,
if you had to,
would be more educational and better for them as humans than learning algebra.
But nobody gives.
I think so. I mean,
I think that's why I also want to go because there's moments like in Thailand
where we're like driving through Thailand and I'm like,
I'd take my phones away and I'm like, look out the window. They're like, yeah.
And I'm like, yeah, this is, you know, you know, uh,
Newark is pretty nice compared to this, you know what I mean? It's like, uh,
by the way, no criticism of Newark,
but the point is point it's like people,
you know, in some of these countries it's like, wow. Yeah,
it must be fascinating for your kids.
Like when they come to work with you and you go into a arena where the bucks
play, you're like, daddy's going to work. It's insane. And go back to school,
dad's truck routes. They, they, they have, you know,
they have no idea and then they cool. And then,
and then they're kind of like, you know, my 13 year old, son's like, you know,
who's really funny.
I was going to say that kid is hilarious when you put them on Instagram.
He's really funny. Yeah. And so like, I have the, you know, um, but it's weird.
Cause like my dad was like a small town banker, you know? It's like you guys,
you know, you know, like, uh, you know, there's nothing prepare you to be the,
a parent who's in the entertainment industry,
unless you're where your parents in that environment. So it's like, it's just,
it's weird. Yeah. You go into parent teacher conferences and they're like,
they're funny. And you're like, I want them to know.
Yeah. Yeah. But that's like, that's like, you know, you mentioned like,
you know your boy on Instagram and your kids on Instagram. You know,
when my daughter was first born, I put a picture of her on Instagram,
on my mother was like, you can't do that.
You can't put your children on Instagram. And then I was like,
look at Jim Gaffigan's Instagram.
I was just like your kid doing something funny with like sucking a noodle.
And she was like, Oh, it's all right. She loves it. She's like, it's all right.
Wait, I think that like, I mean, judging from your daughter's personality,
she probably loves it. Yeah.
She loves it. And you know what? I don't,
I don't just personally like me cause I only got one kid and then you don't have
to pay her either. Exactly. I'm going to keep all that money. If she goes viral,
it's nice check. The kid moves tickets.
Your daughter gets like daughter moves tick yet.
But I got a group chat with my mom, my dad, my step-mom, uh,
my daughter's mother and my daughter's grandmother, her mother's side. And I,
I send a video to that group chat and they,
they all have to approve it before I post it because I don't want it anything to
be like, Oh, what now? Everybody's like, okay,
this is okay to post that's like the definite legal departments.
And the only time, the only time it, you know, if somebody like,
if like my dad's like, I don't think so. I'm like,
why don't you just go gamble my money back to the group chat,
Tony balls.
There was something strange because like, there was like,
I remember I was debating. I was like, this is, you know,